to teach in this old building in London
it was like a former hospital so it was
like the sort of place where you would
set a horror film
this creepy place and I remember
teaching in one of the rooms up in the
top of the building in like these low
ceilings and this kind of dusty
atmosphere I was writing on the board it
was an old crappy old whiteboard and it
was really scratchy and rubbish and also
the wall all around it was really filthy
anyway I was teaching the students
desperately trying to help them learn
English they were all peering through
the darkness to try and actually see the
things I was writing at one point the
whole board just came off the wall and
clattered onto the floor which was a
little embarrassing to say the least now
I tried to carry on you know I lent the
the board up against the wall to keep
going but it didn't work he kept
slipping down so at that point I was
like well what am I going to do how am I
gonna teach these people English on the
wall where the board had been there was
like this empty white space the only
clean part of the wall the paint was
like kind of glossy paint and I realized
that I could just write on the wall and
it was actually better than the board
had been so I just carried on writing
directly onto the wall that was an
interesting experience